right what is going on everybody welcome
to another Python and pandas tutorial
video in this video we're gonna be
talking about is just some quick basic
column manipulation abilities with
pandas so with that let's go ahead and
get started make some space here and
after we've created our data frame one
of the most basic things that we can do
is we can do simple math with each
column so for example we could say DF
something people like to do with stocks
a lot is do the high - the low and so we
could say D upon - low equals D F and
then there's a couple things to ever
really talked about one way to reference
since pandas makes this into an object
what we could do is we can say something
like this like we could say you have
high minus D F low or we could actually
say is this D F dot low okay so when we
reference these things we can either
treat it kind of like a dictionary where
we say it's like that or we can actually
do dot low and just to show you guys
let's go ahead and print DF head
there we go and as you can see we get
this high minus low column and it sure
enough is the high you know say 14 45
minus 14 29 equals fifteen point seven
seven okay now the next thing that we
can do besides simple math on each
column is we can do like there's a lot
of things that are built into pandas so
one of the things that people like also
to do is moving averages or in pandas
rolling mean so for example we could say
DF 100 ma for a 100 moving average
equals P dot rolling underscore mean and
then we want to perform this on what and
we're going to say we're going to
perform this on the clothes column then
the next thing you tell it is how many
periods that we want to use and this is
going to be in our case 100 periods that
we want to do 100 moving average so now
let's go ahead and print DF and here we
can't really be DF head because the
first 100 values is going to be nan not
a number because it's needs 100 periods
so inside print DF 200 to 210 so now we
can save and run this and here is the
100 moving average obviously the other
data is up here just ran out of space so
it comes down here and we can see the
100 moving average here for clothes
closing out of that now another thing
that we can do is we can also perform
calculations on other like using other
rows and so there's some built in it's
kind of hard to do this yourself with
pandas but I'll show you guys probably
know later video how you can map
functions to your pandas columns so
won't be necessarily as efficient as
pandas is but just because you don't
know either what the what the command is
because pretty much with pandas I mean
they have a lot of really great built in
stuff but if you don't know what the
exact thing is that you're looking for
or maybe it doesn't exist you can still
perform function operations by column
using function mappings so I will show
you guys that in a little bit but for
now another thing that we can do is we
can do difference and what difference is
going to do is it's going to tell you
what the difference is between that
column in the previous column
you and so for example and we make a new
column on it basically so we could say
difference equals and we want to let's
say difference closed so we'll say DF
closed dot diff and so what that's going
to do is it's going to make a new column
called difference and that columns
values are going to be basically what's
the difference between the current value
of you know a closed column in our case
what's the difference between that value
in the previous value so now what we can
do print DF towhead save and run it and
out pops this here so we have difference
obviously the first value is not a
number because it doesn't exist our
previous one doesn't exist but then
we've got minus you know nine point
seven seven which in this case closed we
went from 14 36 to 14 26 so yeah nine
point seven seven so anyways those are
just some basic commands again there's a
whole slew of them we'll continue
covering some of the other things that
we can do with pandas that are built-in
and then like I said just because you
can't find a built-in operation you can
always map a function to your panda's
data frame or series so that's always an
option so anyways that's going to
conclude this video if you guys have any
questions or comments for free leave
those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support of
subscriptions and it's a nice time